yes this thing okay so this is followed
genius we're definitely late to this but
yeah we're late we're always we're
always late to this [ __ ] that's not true
we were earlier to the peloton ad right
so we talked about that and like the day
after [ __ ] went viral on everyone's
everyone's talking about it which we
didn't really talk about we just kind of
roasted the abwehr he didn't really talk
about because everyone the whole
dialogue their discourse about this was
about the fact that the husband how
[ __ ] up [ __ ] up it was that the
husband bought the wife a piece of
exercise equipment yeah which I didn't
really think was the issue at all I was
crying at [ __ ] yeah the discussion
around that was hilarious for me because
it I've never seen so many people try to
make something so political yeah you
know I mean like it was it you know yeah
you could make you can make those points
you make those organs but of all the
things going on in the Internet I mean
it's it's obviously just like political
people trying to get views and like
trying to capitalize on it but it was so
funny
watching people try to take something so
[ __ ] asinine just you know what this
means
you know this peloton ad really oh he's
calling her fat he's calling me he's
shaming her but no bread this is a
shitty writer and a shitty marketing guy
at peloton was like ooh this would be
great yeah that's what that is yeah yeah
so anyways this ad goes viral everyone's
[ __ ] talking about it for whatever
reason and I thought the whole thing
with the funny part was her vlogging the
whole [ __ ] yeah that case so then the
next day the next [ __ ] day after this
[ __ ] goes viral this ad comes out for
Ryan Reynolds gin company genius and
it's called the gift that doesn't give
back I mean can we play this even why
not I'm surprised he got this on YouTube
because there's laws around like showing
alcohol on YouTube or no no that that as
it relates to brandy you can just show
the straight of commercial but yeah
we're effectively doing an mid-roll
right now but it's worth watching yeah
[ __ ] war as well yeah yeah
[Music]
[Music]
this gin is really smooth yeah we can
get you another one if you like you're
safe here
to new beginnings it's a new beginning
it's gonna be a fun night continuity
which scripty fired what we're done
ready ready ready ready ready ready
ready ready ready ready ready ready left
hand is up cradling the sip yep next
shot hand down oh I didn't even notice
that at all this see can't enjoy movies
dude I know I did the same [ __ ] man you
ever ever you look great by the way
that's a great [ __ ] tag it's a good
ending line you ever like when you're
watching a movie shoulder shot in a
movie they never I just I always watch
the person the the person whose shoulder
it's over yeah they never may never
[ __ ] match at all anyway so yeah you
want to ruin movie viewing forever yeah
look at the person who's not speaking in
the shot reverse shot yeah that's just
we just [ __ ] movies for you forever
cuz now you'll always do that and it'll
never match what their mouths will never
match what they're saying and it [ __ ]
pisses me off
that's kind of why I like with dialogue
I'm almost stylistically I almost prefer
not to see the other person's mouth
moving yeah I kind of just want to see
just the shoulder yeah or like some or
maybe not even other person at all yeah
you set it up in a medium [ __ ] move
around them get parts of the dialogue
where it's like they're both talking
yeah but don't do the shot reverse yeah
I don't like it yeah anyway yeah this is
great because so this is like a direct
response to the peloton [ __ ] but they
avoid getting sued by not saying
anything about peloton it's just
inferred mm-hmm like there's just the
whole thing is a giant implication of so
smart yeah it's great genius I feel like
Ryan Reynolds is like weirdly good at
this [ __ ]
vert izing no like no I mean like doing
[ __ ] tongue-in-cheek but at like an
a-list level you know I'm saying oh yeah
or he can still be Ryan Reynolds but
like still poke fun at [ __ ] like we do
but you do it yeah like that it's it's
crazy how you know he'd completely just
Ryan Reynolds like after Green Lantern
and this is a you know everyone knows
the story but like yeah I mean as a kid
I always like you know I thought he was
like a clown a little bit I'm like I
he's just like some [ __ ] he had the
[ __ ] college movie he's just a goofy
actor and just that [ __ ] 180 in his
career yeah just like getting Deadpool
done and yeah like showing everyone like
II actually don't know the depth of me
mm-hmm
like he's [ __ ] insanely funny
insanely talented yeah how he approaches
everything yeah like this like it just
shows good looking dude to also [ __ ]
it just wanted to make you feel no no
I'm I'll back that up all day Ryan
Reynolds [ __ ] hot as [ __ ] wait his
wife
played what's-her-face in Gossip Girl I
never watched that show what the [ __ ] is
while you look that up can we just can
we just go to the bit that we were doing
like Lively Blake Lively I've had a
crush on Blake lolly lively for a while
you